Today I have Steve from Steve's Point of
View, and that's not my point of view,
it's Steve who has a channel which he
beams to Japan from the United States and
talks about all kinds of things, including
cars, but he is fluent in Japanese.
And I would like to find out from
Steve, and you can begin then
by introducing yourself, like,
what is it that you do right now?
How did you learn Japanese?
And how did you manage to turn
your knowledge of Japanese into an
activity that is a viable business.
Hajimemashite Steve-san.
Hajimemashite, yoroshiku onegaishimasu.
Uh, thanks, uh, for
having me on your channel.
It's an honor.
I appreciate you having me.
My name is Steve.
Um, I have a channel called Steve's
Point of View or Steve's POV for short.
I am fluent in Japanese.
Um, uh, but I didn't start
off my life that way.
I started studying Japanese, I
really wasn't interested in Japan
until I got to college in 1988
at the university of Wisconsin.
I was a business major
there studying business.
And at the time Japan's
economy was booming.
Uh, there were books being
written about Japan becoming the
number one economy in the world.
It was fascinating for sure.
Uh, and as a business major, I, I,
my goal was to make money and to
try to be successful in business.
And I thought by combining, uh, Japanese
language with my business degree, it
would be a way for me to achieve, uh,
success, uh, working together with Japan.
And, uh, that was my stepping
stone and I got to Japan in
the summer, uh, back in 1991.
I spent three months on a chicken farm
in rural Japan, immersing myself into
the culture, avoided speaking English
for three months and came back to America
with a, uh, a strong, uh, confidence,
I guess that I can learn this language.
I can master the language,
the culture as well.
I can get the, learn it very well
and, uh, be successful that way.
And I won a contest in 1993 called
the Japanese Speech Language Contest.
It's a national contest held in
Chicago and that, that got me, uh,
back to Japan and got me my first job
opportunity there in Japan in 1995.
Interrupt you for just a second, because
you said something that's so important.
You came back confident that
you could learn the language.
I think that's an absolute key, that, that
sense that I can do this thing anyway.
Sorry to interrupt.
But I just thought, I thought
that was such an important thing.
It's a fantastic point, Steve.
I wasn't confident until I went
to Japan, I was not confident.
I was one of the kids in the class
who didn't have any experience
with, with cultural exchanges or,
or homestays or anything like that.
A lot of kids in the class did.
I didn't.
I felt that I, I wasn't very good until I
got to Japan and spent that three months.
And really that was the confidence.
I came back with that confidence
that I could learn this language.
I could speak it.
I could pronounce it.
I can, I could, I could do well with it.
And then, you know, there's another
point of language  you maybe understand
that they say at some point, when
you're learning a language, you
start to dream in the language.
You start to, you start to speak
the language in your dreams.
And that, after that point is when
I started actually having dreams
in Japanese and somebody told me at
that point, that's when you know you,
I just mastered or to some degree,
you know, you've got the language.
And, uh, that day came and, uh, and
from there I got back to Japan, started
working, uh, worked, uh, for a Japanese
company for about a year and a half
or so before I ventured off on my own.
And I started, uh, doing, uh, translating
and importing and exporting and all
kinds of stuff in Japan as a foreigner,
uh, back in the early nineties, uh, long
way through there, back to the United
States and California to now, to Texas.
But I started YouTube
about seven years ago.
Uh, the passion of doing so was to
show people, uh, there is a Japanese
speaking, um, non-Japanese person here
in north America who, uh, understands
business and would love to work
together and, and venture with people.
And that was the purpose
of starting steve's POV.
And, uh, thankfully here,
about seven years later, almost
400,000 subscribers strong.
Uh, the channel is, um, something
that's fun to do along with my real
estate business as well here in Texas.
So you have a real estate business in
Texas, and then you have this, this
YouTube channel, and I know you're very
interested in cars, but, uh, do you
just talk about cars, uh, or does your
point of view include, you know, Steve,
uh, you know, ranting on, like I do
on a variety of different subjects in
Japanese, uh, that your Japanese audience
finds interesting, or is it mostly cars?
Well, Um, lately it's been mostly
cars, but the channel started with
something from my POV, the point of
view that I had in living and working
in Japan, living and experiencing
Japanese culture and being an American.
And then coming back to the American,
America and with a fresh Japanese work
mindset, that way of doing things and
coming back to America and experiencing
a bit of culture shock, but even
as an American back in from Japan.
And I started making videos
where I played a Japanese salary
man and a Japanese salesman in
the same kind of short parad...
parody type setting.
And it shows kind of those big
differences between Japan and America.
Sorry, did you say a Japanese
salary man and a Japanese salesman?
American salesman.
American Salesman.
American salesman versus
Japanese salesman.
Okay, sorry.
No problem.
Sorry.
I might've missed that.
Um, so, and you know, they're
very different Japanese, you
know, the necktie's on you're
very, you know, you're suited up.
You're, you're very stiff.
You're very rigid.
You're very manual in many
ways, there's way to do things.
And there's only one way
to do things and yeah.
And then Americans were a little
more laid back, but you know,
my feet are up on the desk guys.
T-shirts on Fridays and we're out of the
office at 2.30, we got a baseball game
for the kids, you know, it's, uh, it,
these are things in Japan you didn't have.
I found those differences
very interesting.
And I put some videos out
about them that did very well.
You know, one of the big differences
in my experience is in Japan, if you
are dealing with someone in business,
then you say, can you do this?
And they said, "Hmm, do
desho", very difficult.
That means he's going to do it.
Uh, in the north America.
If you say, can you do this?
Oh yeah, no problem.
Uh, maybe, and maybe not.
Maybe, maybe not.
And everything's the best here.
You know, we talk about us a lot.
Oh the best.
And it's mine.
That's very personalized.
You could be working for a company
here, but you talking about my
warehouse, my products, my guy in
the warehouse, my guy in the back,
you know, it's very personalized.
You're in Japan.
It's about the group.
It's about the company.
It's about the bigger, uh, entity.
Plus in Japan, they don't necessarily,
because you say my product is the best,
that, they don't necessarily believe that,
you know, just because you say yours is
the best, you may not be convincing anyone
and maybe you want to try to persuade
them that you're going to try hard to,
you know, look after your customer,
rather than just saying mine is the best.
There's a bit more of a humble approach,
I think, to, uh, to what you have there.
Yep, definitely.
It's not that hard, maybe sales push,
or maybe as hard of a, you know,
there's the best you've got to try the
better, it's more of a humble approach.
And you know, that's all
built into the culture too.
So when you learn Japanese language,
right, Steve, it's not just learning
"nani nani desu", "nani nani masu" you
know, you know, the basic Japanese words,
but it's, it's learning that culture.
And then the hierarchal Japanese society
and how you humble yourself or elevate
others, and how you talk to somebody older
than yourself, or a teacher or a Shōchō,
a president in a, in a company versus the
guy who works below you in the company.
It's very different.
It's a different mindset
that you need to understand.
But, but, uh, one thing I would say
about that is that first of all, because
Japan has had a different history and
is from a very different culture, it
doesn't mean that a North American
can't learn that just as a Japanese
person can learn the North American way.
And so I definitely feel that,
I mean, I can go over there and
feel I'm integrated in with them.
I mean, they look at me, I look a
little different, but culturally, in
terms of what we're saying to each
other, we're all operating kind of
in the same cultural environment.
Uh, that was one point.
And I think another important point
is you can't read a book which
tells you how you should behave.
And when you use the polite form
and then expect to apply that you
actually have to live it until
you start to feel it naturally.
Exactly true.
And that's part of going there and,
you know, there's a lot of foreigners
that were in Japan, uh, now, you know,
and over the years, more and more
have increased and you see a lot of
foreigners stay together with other
foreigners that there's, you know, there
are people who are with Japanese, of
course, but if you really want to learn,
you've got to go out with Japanese in
different social situations, whether
it's eating, whether it's drinking,
whether it's studying together or
whatever, it may be working together and
to understand those non-language, the
non-language language, and the gestures.
And, but some of the differences,
differences that are there that
unless you experience it, like
you said, you can't just learn it
in, in a, in a book necessarily.
No, no.
And I think it's important to then
want to be part of that group.
And the same applies in reverse.
If a Japanese person comes to North
America, you have to want, or anybody
learning any language, you have
to want to be part of that group.
And, and it's it's, if you're very
self-conscious of yourself, here I
am, I'm an American or a Canadian
I'm in amongst all these Japanese.
And, and somehow the fact that
I'm this American speaking
Japanese is somehow important.
All of that is negative.
You're just there, one of them, part
of the group, uh, that's been my
experience that leads to acquiring the
language and feeling part of a group.
If you go there and you act like, you
know, Hey, well, I'm an American, I
do things differently and all that.
So you're, you're gonna,
you're going to fail.
I, I, in my opinion, in, in,
um, in really understanding and
appreciating and learning Japanese
culture and the beauty of it.
I think you need to go overe
there as if somebody comes here,
it's not, you know, you have your
culture, you have your identity.
That's great.
But you know, you're in their country.
You're a guest in that country.
There are certain rules and certain
formal things that are done.
And believe me, if you don't
follow those, you'll see maybe some
people say, well, he's American,
you know, or he's a foreigner.
So, you know, we'll give him a pass on it.
But if you're there and really trying to
assimilate and you're doing stupid stuff,
you're going to get called out on it.
But I think though it's important
not to over sort of dramatize this.
Like sometimes you'll get Americans going
over there, they're bowing 90 degrees.
You know, you have to feel it.
You have to have, you know, sensitive
tenticles, antenna that, that
you start to feel it naturally.
And so it's comfortable doing it.
You don't want to be doing
something that's uncomfortable.
I mean, of course you'd take your
shoes off before you walk in a house.
But other than that, I don't think
people need to be so uptight.
If they just naturally connect with
people, person to person, they'll
gradually start to see how other people
behave and start behaving the same way.
Just as we acquire language through
imitation, we acquire that, that
cultural communication skill
through just letting it come.
You know?
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Tell me...
Please go ahead with your question
but I agree with your point.
No I was going to say, what is it now?
What is the appeal to your viewer base,
400,000 subscribers, that's a lot.
Uh, what is it you think that they
find appealing in your videos?
I think they, they find
appealing a couple of things.
One, the fact that I'm located
in the United States, I'm, I'm
not Japanese, but I'm doing my,
provide my shows in Japanese.
That I've raised a son here in the
United States who was born in California,
now in Texas is 21 years old
who speaks Japanese fluently.
He's comfortable doing it and he's not,
um, um, ashamed or embarrassed in any way.
I think there's something unique
and completely different about that.
Um, I also try to point out in my videos,
even if they're about cars, the cultural
differences, whether it be how a box is
packed, that came from Japan and how it's
wrapped and presented versus something
that showed up from just down the street
that looks like it just went through,
you know, all around the world and under
the ocean and everywhere else and back.
You know, these, these things, I
try, I think people maybe find that
point of view interesting, um, a
father, son relationship as well.
Certainly part of it as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, the Japanese attention to detail.
If they're going to do something,
they're going to do it 110 percent.
Whereas they're in north
America, 65% is good.
Maybe
Sometimes.
We shouldn't be...yeah.
Okay.
Well, uh, we're going to have a chat
on your channel in Japanese, and I'm
certainly going to leave a link to
your channel in my description box.
So we can continue this conversation in
Japanese and see where that takes us.
But thank you very much.
And I hope your example will be an
inspiration to people who follow
my channel, who are interested
in learning Japanese or any
other language for that matter.
Thanks Steve
Thank you, Steve.
Bye for now.